he didn't remember what country he last
visited
last week he he didn't remember top gun
Maverick okay we've got a big problem
anyway so today even Democrats on
Capitol Hill they're telling foxnews.com
that Biden's Health mental stamina
unmatched really do you believe that
take a look
as he says every day watch me and he
puts many of us to shame with his energy
he is you know as as I as I age I
appreciate wisdom even more no no no not
at all not at all we've had many leaders
uh his age that have done extraordinary
things to our American and there's no
reason why he can't accomplish this uh
just as much or more in his second term
as he did in his first can you ask for
any more experience vice president
president Senator experience really
counts especially in the world today
that is so dangerous I think he's the
right guy at the right time
he has proven he can deliver
all right does anyone believe Mr Fang
Fang because I don't look clearly they
are lying there is no doubt that Biden
has really bad memory problems his
cognitive decline we pointed it out
first it is so clear and obvious and
transparent this guy has no business
running for a second term that is for
sure but not just because of his mental
and physical Decay Joe Biden is not a
good guy he's a president by the way he
is now hurting every single person in
this country in every way imaginable now
just listen as Joe was describing his
wonderful loving relationship with all
of his grandchildren minus one a
four-year-old little granddaughter that
Joe Biden refuses to recognize or even
acknowledge in any way shape manner
reform take a look
I have six grandchildren and I'm crazy
about them and I speak to them every
single day not a joke okay Joe Biden has
seven grandchildren not six
grandchildren and he doesn't speak to
one of them at all I'll use his word
it's no it's not a joke I'm serious uh
Hey Joe come on man it's a little child
it's your granddaughter you can't
acknowledge her that is really pathetic
this four-year-old little girl has done
nothing wrong and yet there is no love
no support no invites to the White House
no Christmas presents no birthday cards
you don't hang up a stocking at
Christmas uh not from Joe not from Jill
nobody that is a disgrace they should
all be ashamed of themselves and of
course Hunter Biden has been ordered by
a judge now to make child support
payments following a paternity test but
now Hunter's attorneys have been working
overtime to reduce or eliminate those
payments now they're claiming that
Hunter just doesn't have enough money
money from Russia China and Ukraine to
support his own daughter despite all of
these overseas business dealings and his
widely successful career as an amateur
artist paint by numbers I call it
portraits of a crack addict uh that he
sells to mysterious buyers for what a
half a million dollars but hunter Biden
he just doesn't have any money to spare
for his own kid now of course pops or
the multi-millionaire lifelong Public
Service Joe while he's not willing to
lend a hand a helping hand in any way he
doesn't care about his own four-year-old
granddaughter now here's the big
question of the day imagine if this
granddaughter was Donald Trump's
granddaughter do you think the media
would ignore this
I don't think so either he has the gall
to pretend that he's this wonderful
loving Family Guy it is one big lie and
let me say this again Joe Biden has a
chip missing if he thinks that this is
in any way okay that girl deserves love
Joe man up and love your granddaughter
it's that simple
anyway that's news to Kareem Jean-Pierre
take a look at what she had to say about
it
breaking news about about the president
so his favorite ice cream
is graters readers how do you greeters
graders I don't eat ice cream don't shhh
I know chocolate chip and he loves a
good pair of sunglasses he likes
spaghetti
which is
pretty cool I love spaghetti too like
spaghetti with red sauce and so that's
one of his favorite meals all right Joey
likes ice cream spaghetti and all every
grandchild except for the four-year-old
she's on her own now of course Joe also
loves a good cheat sheet and a compliant
media mob take a look at your screen now
this is a picture of a note card that
Biden was holding yesterday at a press
conference entitled reporter q a with
the sub headline question number one
followed by a reporter's name her
picture and where she works the LA Times
and the card also detailed the exact
question she wanted to ask it was about
semiconductor manufacturing and right on
cue Biden called on the LA Times
Reporter for the first question and
guess what she asked about semiconductor
manufacturing but now the LA Times and
the Biden White House they're denying
that there was any collusion at all
whatsoever take a look
the LA Times said that their reporter
did not submit any questions in advance
of yesterday's press conference so to
people who saw that pocket card can you
explain how that ended up there and why
the president needed something like that
look we we do not have specific
questions in advance that's not
something that we do our job is to get a
sense of what you all want to ask him
that is our job here to get a sense of
what's uh the the news of the day the
topics you all are interested uh for for
to ask of him
okay why lie that there is photographic
evidence that Biden got the question in
advance as Senator Marco Rubio tweeted
quote Biden has the media in his pocket
and it's literally it's really in his
pocket uh by the way we knew this for
years right didn't we always know that
they were an extension of the Biden
press office right and anyway so this is
not journalism this is teamwork Biden
and the mob are operating as one unit
now if this was the Trump White House
you know fake news CNN and MSNBC and of
course ABC CBS The New York Times they
would have a total meltdown fit over all
of this Jim Acosta probably he'd be
crying Humpty Dumpty would be apoplectic
by the way he's been M.I.A does anyone
know where Humpty is gone lately I have
no idea but because Biden is a Democrat
he gets a pass just business as usual
and the so-called journalists wonder why
America Americans no longer trust the
media can they really be this stupid but
one thing is clear as 2024 now nears the
media's Biden Protection Program is back
it is more corrupt than ever before and
mark my words this night he will once
again run a campaign from his basement
and he will hide hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else